derrick's in kansas city hi derek how
are you
[Music]
oh mr ramsay i'm doing well how are you
doing better than i deserve how can we
help
oh good hey so i got a question my
growing up uh i wasn't super financially
responsible
and yeah i think that's how we are as
kids um
try not to be i've gotten a lot better
um
over the years credit score got high i
ended up moving from san diego to kansas
city about three years ago
i had some credit card debt that i
turned into being irresponsible again
probably
i don't know five years ago um ended up
getting charged off
and i owe about 8 900 well i got a
notification in the mail the other day
about a court hearing on the 30th of
this month
um obviously to get their money back
which is fair
um i guess my question is uh what i've
done is i called them and tried to do a
settlement
for a percentage of the total amount
they agreed to it
um i just agreed to a higher rate than i
was comfortable paying at the time
and now i'm left with the decision of do
i pay that amount or i also have a truck
that i only owe
8 200 on if i pay that
off do you have any money
i do so i have about 12 000 in savings
okay what can you get the credit card
company to agree to settle for right now
um
five thousand okay that's pretty high
how old is the debt
oh gosh i would say five years uh
four they were they paid about a nickel
on the dollar for it
okay so on a ten thousand dollar debt
they paid 500 bucks for it okay
roughly would you recommend getting an
attorney i got a ton of emails
no i just want you to eat them i just
want you to beat on them a little harder
and get them down to about 3k
three okay i had offered 35 yeah after
doing some research online and yeah
there's like 60 and they said no that
that company will never go that low
and yeah you know yes they will um i
know it so what you've got to do is just
keep messing with them and just go well
i you know i have four thousand dollars
if you want to settle this today
we can settle it today now here's a
couple of rules
number one you can tell a credit card
collector is lying if their mouth is
moving
it's scum that you're dealing with sure
bottom feeders and so and if you're a
credit card
collector out there and you don't like
me saying that you should get a
different job to prove that you're not
scum
so uh because nobody stays in that
business it's not scummy it is a
nasty butt business they lie
i am not kidding you we've dealt with
them for 30 years
major household names like american
express
bank of america citibank will lie
to you it is unbelievable okay
it's hard to believe and you think i'm
being melodramatic i'm not i've done
this for a long time
first time or two it happened to me i
was shocked but it's just the way it is
so get it in writing or it didn't happen
okay and it can be an email that's fine
but an email from that organization it
with the account number on it
and it says this account is settled in
full
if you pay four thousand dollars by
january 15th or whatever okay
rule number one in writing or it didn't
happen rule number two is they do not
get electronic access
to your checking account under any
circumstances
they will clean you out they'll take 8
900 out of your
account if you give them the account
that's got 8 900 in it
and then try to get that back because
you owe it you're not getting it back
so you need a prepaid debit card that is
transacted one time
and then closed a wire is fine
but i i wouldn't give them electronic
access to a bank account under
any circumstances a traditional bank
account because they'll take your money
out there and you won't be able to pay
your rent
okay in writing no electronic access to
your checking account
got it yes sir and you ought to be able
to get them down to four anyway you
already got them to five
i'm really surprised they wouldn't take
3 500 i really am
yeah so i guess it's is that normal for
it's not at this agency anymore i don't
know if i'm allowed to say the company
they bounce it around all over the place
they've probably sold the debt for a
nickel on the dollar and the people
collecting it are sitting in a boiler
room
with a you know there's a whole room
full of cubicles with people with
headsets on dialing people like you
okay yeah that's fair it's an attorney i
ended up calling that no they're not
they work for an attorney and they saw
72 000 of them in this one room
it's a boiler room they have one
attorney in there and you're just
you're just a widget this is not matlock
so do you think the 3000 or 3500 i
should be good with that or should it be
three to four if you can settle this for
three or four and you've got the money
and you can get it out of your life
finally
get it out of your life but again in
writing no electronic access your
checking account
okay you're dealing with a debt buyer
they bought
a million dollars worth of debt for a
nickel on the dollar and they're out
there collecting it and they finally
found somebody that their phone number
actually worked
sure or you called them so now they got
your phone number do not give them any
information by the way on you
like where you work or anything else
about you
yeah that's too late so they had asked
that i'd let them know um
didn't know i should have called you
sooner yeah well they're going to use
that against you too because they're
going to garnish your dead gum wages if
they take this judgment now
or they'll call you where you work yeah
they're going to bug the crap out of you
tell your admin or your boss so settle
this three four five
thousand somewhere in there get it
settled uh you know
uh and you know i would just tell the
guy listen i have money in my hand
if you want credit for this account
before christmas we can do the deal
right now
you want to play let's dance baby and
just mess with him
because he's not used to actually
talking to people he's used to leaving
voicemails all day long and he actually
talking to a person
he doesn't he's about to wet himself he
doesn't know how to handle this and
you're dealing with a guy who's not been
on the job even 90 days
their turnover rate inside these
collection companies like this is about
40 days
most people make it a a month and 10
days and then they're gone to something
else because it's a job it's the worst
job in the world it sucks
how would you like to call people all
day long and mess with them
oh god i mean you got to have
psychological disorder to do that as a
career
and so um anyway that's who you're
dealing with is some kid
in a cubicle 500 miles away with a
headset on
think of every movie you've ever seen
you've got it in your head right
that's the deal and just you know just
mess with them
and that it's not a lawyer there is a
lawyer somewhere in the background
but there's there's you're not talking
to a lawyer you're not even talking to a
paralegal
you're not even talking anybody who
could pass the first week of a paralegal
test
so not even close so just mess with them
and push on through and you'll get there